as I was listening to your recent
podcast I thought that of a few topics
you could discuss that would be good and
helpful for young guys who want to join
the military and go special-ops I know
that buds and other training are just
baseline entry-level schools but in my
experience those stories are what get
guys excited and fired up so you know
guy wants to hear about Bud stories and
what it's like going through those
stories through those types of training
because it gets people excited and fired
up well there's there's actually kind of
a reason why I don't sit around and talk
about buds which is basic steel basic
underwater demolition SEAL training
there's a reason I don't sit around and
talk about it a bunch one of those
reasons is because buds is not the SEAL
Teams at all and it doesn't mean
anything and I try and say that as often
as I can because I don't want people to
get the impression that that the SEAL
Teams is the little initial training
that is barely even a fraction of your
career in the SEAL Teams and it has
nothing to do with what you actually do
when you get in the SEAL Teams I also
don't want and this is an intentional
this is more of a response to the
question but I don't tell stories to get
guys fired up to join the military about
buds because that isn't what the SEAL
Teams is that's not what an SF oda team
is that's not what Ranger Battalion is
Ranger Battalion and SF is not the
selection course to that you go through
to get into them that's not what the job
is and you shouldn't be joining the
military and shouldn't be trying to get
into Special Operations because you want
to do that training you should do the
training because you want to do the job
you want to do the actual job of being
in Special Operations and be in Special
Forces and being Rangers
being in MARSOC and being in the SEAL
team she didn't want to do that job and
if you want to do that job what it
really boils down to isn't running or
rocking or pull-ups or swimming or any
that crap it boils down to whether you
have the two wills that I talked about
that war is determined by and that is
the will to kill because that is the
entire premise of your job if you're in
the military at all you may be somehow
supporting that if you're in the
military but the ultimate goal of the
military is to kill the bad guys and if
you're gonna be in Special Operations
you're gonna be on the tip of the spear
of that so you absolutely have to make
sure that you have the will to kill and
you also obviously if you're gonna join
Special Operations or you want to be in
the SEAL Teams you have to have the will
to die not that you want to die not that
you want to be a martyr not that you're
freaking suicidal or anything like that
but you absolutely have to make sure
that you have the willingness to die and
I would say put your life on the line
but no I'm going beyond that I'm talking
about the willingness to die because if
you join Special Operations or you join
the SEAL Teams or you join any of the
combat arms in the army or in the Marine
Corps you will be asked to put your life
on the line and you got to be ready to
do that
you gotta have that will you got to be
ready to make that commitment and I mean
the training if you if you have that
will to kill and you have that will to
die the training Ronda swim
do push-ups to pull-ups dips Princeton
rope climbs to flutter kicks all that
stuff it's the easy part and so if
you're sitting there and you see SEAL
training on TV and you think oh that'd
be cool don't think about that as what
being a seal is because it is not that
is just the selection it's just the
weeding out of the week if you want to
be a seal means you want to be a
commando it means you want to go into
harm's way it means you wanna meet the
enemy on the field of battle
that's what being a seal is
and that's why I really don't sit around
and tell bud stories I don't think I
have too much more to say about that one
I'm sure at some point okay I mean
there's funny things that happened in
buds I mean of course but just compared
to like what happens in a seal platoon
they're just no big deal yeah yeah it's
interesting that you put it
don't focus don't do it cuz you want to
go through that yeah do it because you
want to do the job yeah that's a big
that's a big mistake maybe I can help
some people out that are out there right
now thinking oh I'd really like to go
through that training mmm-hmm no don't
do it to go through the training go it
do it because you want to do that job
yeah is it true they they they take a
pin and they stick it in your skin and
clip it pin it on your skin did you they
do that well when you get your Trident
yeah the the it has like three little
prongs that go out the back of it to
stick it onto your uniform mm-hmm and
when you get your Trident yeah they put
it like into your skin yeah this is like
you're standing there with no shirt
they're like oh yeah and then they like
punch it in and then you know everybody
when I went when I got my Trident the
whole team lined up and everyone punch
you right in the chest until you just
bleeding everywhere the big bruise on
your chest yeah